etwas mehr als eine woche nach dem
horror von hanau ist klar deutschland
hat ein konsequent unterschätztes
problem mit terror von rechts und mit
rassismus ja alltagsrassismus ein thema
dem wir uns endlich mal stellen müssen
auch wenn es weh tut
du siehst rassismus ist ein thema wir
müssen darüber reden wir haben hier
menschen fern drüber geredet und müssen
leider bei der sendung zu ende geht
haben sie merken wir sind ein stück ein
bisschen ins schleudern gekommen
ja wichtig ist dass man darüber redet
absolut was menschen die nicht deutsch
genug aussehen bei uns immer öfter
erleben ist wirklich eine schande und
zwar nicht nur im internet wo man ja
schon alles gewöhnt ist sondern auf der
straße ganz offen bedroht bepöbelt
angespuckt man könnte auch sagen gelebte
rassismus ist längst angekommen in der
mitte unserer gesellschaft
ich bin heute freiheit 7 erste mal mit
meinen hund gegangen
da kann noch so schön vielleicht zehn
mann im ausland konnten diese frühe halb
sieben her
also ich war sprachlos ich so etwas
langsam ungemütlich
[Applaus]
mit
karin rentnerinnen beschweren sich über
frühaufsteher das ist nicht mehr mein
deutschland freunde und rassismus hat
viele gesichter leider da sagen zum
beispiel patienten zu hier geborenen
ärzten mit türkischen wurzeln
sie sprechen aber gut deutsch wo kommen
sie denn ursprünglich her kommt ständig
die frage und damit muss man umgehen und
dass das dahinter steht ja die aller
spannendste frage ab wann gehört man
hier bei uns zum wir was muss man machen
um hier zum wir dazu zu gehören
nach einer aktuellen umfrage hat zum
beispiel jeder dritte deutsche mit
migrationshintergrund schon
diskriminierung bei der wohnungssuche
erlebt der 35 jährige ingenieur mehmedi
war monatelang auf wohnungssuche in
berlin erfolglos
bei einer wohnung bewerber sich dann
nach der absage noch mal diesmal mit
einem fiktiven deutschen namen und schon
bekam er eine einladung
siehste und hätte sich dabei noch eine
perücke aufgesetzt hatte die wohnung
sogar gekriegt genau diese art
diskriminierung ist übrigens laut
gleichbehandlungsgesetz ausdrücklich
verboten allerdings gibt es da ja
schlupflöcher vermieter dürfen nämlich
in ihren objekten auf die zitat
schaffung ausgeglichener kultureller
verhältnisse achten zitat ende
sie merken da ist
interpretationsspielraum was ist
kulturell ausgeglichen
am besten erkläre ich ihnen das mal
anhand von barbies traumhaus ja das ist
so überhaupt nicht ausgeglichen nur
deutsche da muss der vermieter also auch
mal ausländer reinlassen ausländer
samara ein ehepaar aus norwegen genau
plus weiß ich nicht
zwei geile schweden aber diese
hausgemeinschaft akzeptiert natürlich
auch türken also einen türken und nur
wenn er im erdgeschoss kiosk aufmacht
und nach mitternacht noch bier verkauft
jetzt im handel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kurz zu recht ausgeglichen
bei der jobsuche erleben leute mit
ausländischen namen das gleiche angela
merkel sagt rassismus ist ein gift das
sie natürlich völlig recht das ist ein
gift allerdings und das ist viel
spannender wer sind die dealer da fällt
einem natürlich wie immer zuerst die afg
ein ja die afd deren anhänger die partei
laut einer aktuellen studie der uni
leipzig nicht trotz sondern wegen ihrer
antidemokratischen und rassistischen
programmatik wählen da verstehen viele
jetzt gar nicht wo das problem sein soll
wo würden sie dann die grenze ziehen
nach rechtsaußen nachricht aus in welche
richtung die
jawohl einen daumen links ist von dir
ausgesehen
von mir aus gesehen rechts sr wurscht
ist ja wurscht und keine frage wir
könnten jetzt zur beweisführung wieder
bernd werke mit seinem afrikanischen
ausbreitung typ 1 spielen oder die weidl
mit ihren messern mädchen und kopftuch
männern oder umgekehrt aber warum warum
sollten wir das immer wieder zeigen es
liegt ja alles öfter haben sie kennen
das auch alles hanau wäre für die afg
also eine wirklich top gelegenheit zu
ernsthafter selbstreflexion oder
natürlich zur selbstmitleid hetze gegen
die afd
ich finde es schäbig wie weit sind wir
eigentlich gekommen zweitens finde ich
es schäbig wurde das eigentlich noch
hinführen bei der art von ausgrenzung
und derart auch entschuldigung von hetze
gegen uns nazis ach so ja
die erfinder der ausgrenzung beweinen
ihre ausgrenzung warum nicht warum nicht
immerhin hat sich die bundespartei der
ft inzwischen deutlich von ekelhaften
malbuch der fdp-fraktion
nordrhein-westfalen distanziert und sie
das mitgekriegt dieses mal buch ja da
gab es unter anderem bilder wie das hier
wo ihm von ausländern gekaperten freibad
burka frauen zur arschbombe ansetzen und
afrikaner ernsthaft mit knochen im haar
gezeigt werden wie im 40er jahre cartoon
oder habe ich da was falsch verstanden
die afg allerdings will hier keine
schwarzen mit knochen in den haaren
sehen laut des vorsitzenden der fdp
landtagsfraktion nrw markus wagner
handle es sich um badekappen von
mitteleuropäer rinnen bald im afg
fanshop die badekappe für
mitteleuropäische frau
ja
würde ich so gern sehen wie der bern
damit im körper vom zehner machen naja
so selbstverständlich ums abzuschließen
selbstverständlich ist die afg eine
durch und durch rassistische partei
trotzdem ist es ein bisschen billig wenn
jetzt zum beispiel die union so tut als
habe die afg rassismus und ressentiments
quasi erfunden gab es hier leider schon
vor 2013
und es ist ja auch nicht so lange her
dass diese herren hier über migration
als mutter aller probleme oder asyl
tourismus schwadroniert haben ja auch
unions politiker reden zwanghaft immer
von rechts und links terrorismus als
wäre das selbe nach 182 toten durch
rechten terror seit der
wiedervereinigung
kurz vor hanno ist ja gerade die so
genannte gruppe teutonico aufgeflogen
die geld und waffen für anschläge auf
moscheen gesammelt hat und da war schon
wieder ein verwaltungsmann dabei der für
die polizei arbeitet ja wie man
wie man bei aktenzeichen xy sagt leider
kein einzelfall rechte polizisten teilen
in chat gruppen regelmäßig sowas hier
dort hatte ein dienstgruppenleiter einen
deutschen weihnachtsgruß und weitere
rechtsextreme bilder verschickt zum
beispiel hakenkreuz kekse roma hat
plätzchen gebacken sind nur etwas braun
geworden
ja die oma macht übrigens auch einen
hervorragenden ss steuern aber das nur
am rande um bei rechten netzwerken wie
nordkreuz haben sich polizisten
verfassungsschützer und soldaten sogar
auf einen umsturz vorbereitet einen ja
nix mit feindes oder todeslisten und
leichensäcken die die schon gestellt
hatten klar man muss dankbar sein um das
klar zu sagen man muss dankbar sein für
jeden der bei sicherheitsbehörden den
kopf für uns alle hinhält und die ganz
große masse steht selbstverständlich auf
dem boden der verfassung
trotzdem sagt das einiges wenn unser
innenminister seehofer jetzt eine und
ist kein witz zentralstelle zur
aufklärung rechtsextremistischer
umtriebe im öffentlichen dienst
einrichtet ja so wird die heißen genau
da schauen wir jetzt mal hin zu dennis
knossalla pressesprecher der neuen
behörde
herr knossalla was genau machen sie denn
da also hier dreht sich eigentlich alles
nur um eine frage woran erkenne ich denn
überhaupt einen rechtsextremen
polizisten oder verfassungsschützer
nicht so einfach ich mag diese leute
tragen ja jetzt in aller regel leider
kein t shirt wo draufsteht rechtsextreme
neben verwaltungsbeamten bei der polizei
haben der jetzt mit teutonico
aufgeflogen ist woran hätte man erkennen
sollen dass der rechts ist 20 18 wurden
2 reiß kriegs werken auf seinem balkon
gemeldet er trug kleidungsstücke die
auch von personen der rechten szene
getragen werden
gut das sind jetzt magie indizien
springerstiefel tragen viele leute auch
aus orthopädischen gründen wie gesagt
nie vorschnell urteilen bei einem
polizisten aus köln sind wir neulich
stutzig geworden wegen seines
nummernschildes a-ha 88 jahr da denkt
man erst mal nicht gut aber dann hat es
mir der kollege
er ist 1988 geboren und riesen fan von
anton hofreiter
kurz gesagt so einfach ist es nicht
und nochmal die allermeisten machen ja
einen super job aber die tatsache dass
seehofer so eine behörde einrichtet
zeigt doch wir haben ein problem
keine frage ich sage nur racial
profiling also dass polizisten menschen
ab einem bestimmten pigmentierung der
haut öfter kontrollieren auch dafür
wollen wir hier sensibilisieren in
speziellen übungen hier simulieren wir
gerade folgendes nach einem einbruch
sind zwei verdächtige verhaftet und
jetzt sollen die jungen polizisten sich
eben nicht von der hautfarbe
beeinflussen lassen das ist ja ganz
wichtig genau das ist ja
alltagsrassismus sich das bewusst zu
machen ist ja schon der erste schritt
absolut und was machen wir jetzt konkret
gegen rechtsextreme im öffentlichen
dienst da gibt es viele tolle ideen
rechtsextreme geben sich betont männlich
und fühlen sich magisch angezogen von
uniformen auch deswegen gibt es aktuell
550 verdachtsfälle
allein bei der bundeswehr besonders
betroffen unser kommando spezialkräfte
die einheit für die ganz harten jungs
und genau da setzen wir jetzt an und
ändern die ksk uniformen so dass rechte
die nie mehr tragen wollen hier neues
modell
gute neuigkeiten für unsere zeit ist
wieder ein bisschen ausruhen und muslime
wenn das nicht hilft dennis knossalla
mal damen und herren
vielen dank
wie wollen wir in deutschland zusammen
leben was reicht uns da als regelwerk
das sind fragen die nie aufhören
wichtige fragen und vor allem die
diskussion über die sogenannte deutsche
leitkultur ist inzwischen fester
bestandteil unserer folklore
das heißt sie kommt mindestens ein mal
im jahr wie keine ahnung der tag des
deutschen butterbrots oder sowas
erstmals hat mir die debatte vor genau
20 jahren damals angeschoben von wer
weiß es friedrich merz und aktuell schon
wieder wegen eines leitkultur aufsatzes
von philippe am tor unserem
klassenbesten
das muss gefeiert werden friedemann
weise ratschläge in die fresse mit
friedemann weise
kaum zu glauben 20 jahre leitkultur
debatte
wenn das kein grund zum feiern ist
[Applaus]
sondern sie sich auch gefreut oder seit
dem jahr 2000 kommt jedes jahr irgend
ein männlicher unionspolitiker um die
ecke und fordert eine deutsche
leitkultur die neueste forderung kam
letzte woche von philippe am tor hier
als leitkultur verkleidet das muss man
sich mal vorstellen als friedrich merz
die debatte damals anfing war am tor
gerade mal sieben wirklich und immer
noch die gleiche brille und das thema
ist immer noch die gleiche debatte wenn
eine debatte in 20 jahren zu absolut gar
nichts führt muss man sich vielleicht
mal fragen ob sie überhaupt nötig ist
wir haben noch das grundgesetz
da steht alles drin was man für ein
friedliches miteinander braucht
na gut das und vielleicht noch die
hausordnung ok und die mülltonnen regeln
sehr gute und der putzplan der deutsche
braucht eben immer alles schriftlich
sogar fürs kappen will ein beleg von
sanifair die idee von einer leitkultur
für ganz deutschland ist einfach nicht
zeitgemäß
mein ratschlag naturbelassene
nachhaltige regionale leid kulturen zum
beispiel der karneval im rheinland
regionale leitkultur mit großem sinn für
integration der crashkurs karneval für
anfänger in einem caritas zentrum soll
asylbewerbern genau das vermitteln
schunkeln inklusive sie müssen wissen
wie es geht also uns erschrecken sie
sich schon denken wir sind verrückt das
stimmt auch ein bisschen aber man sollte
erklären dass das auch wieder aufhört
und wieder weggeht wieder weggeht also
bei manchen mehr bei anderen weniger
regionale leitkultur funktioniert halt
nur in der region wenn zum beispiel
rheinische jecken in berlin auftreten
freut sich auch nicht jeder
aber er ist okay jede region hat eben
ihre eigene tradition in münchen das
oktoberfest an der mosel die weinfeste
in westfalen die schützenfeste und im
rest von deutschland da sollte man halt
ohne grund wissen viele gar nicht
alkohol ist ja auch wichtig für die
arterhaltung hinter der leitkultur
debatte steckt einfach die angst vor
veränderung alle träumen davon
samstagabends wieder frisch gebadet in
frottee schlafanzug auf der couch zu
sitzen und wetten dass zu gucken aber
diese zeiten sind nun mal vorbei für
immer und die kommen nicht zurück war
der fahrer dieser welt vereinigt euch
wir greifen im november noch einmal an
wetten dass
was das ist ein aktueller trailer
ich glaub das ist deutsche leitkultur
dass ich im fernsehen nie was ändert
werden das kommt zurück verstehen sie
spaß wird 40 sonntags immer tatort und
ich weiß auch wer in 30 jahren die heute
show moderiert ich hatte gehofft
christian ehring alter der club hatte er
wieder alles so wahnsinn inhaltlich
stark satire comedy gold ich habe es
noch drauf also ich würde den kanal
direkt abonnieren und auf gefällt mir
drücken wenn ich das nicht so getan
hätte das war wirklich stark
[Musik]